we welcome you back to CBS mornings we
want to share a CBS News investigation
into what it is literally a life or
death situation for many Americans more
than 100 000 people in this country are
waiting for an organ transplant right
now think about that for a second but
only slightly more than half that number
are expected to receive an organ within
five years now we've got exclusive
details from a conver now we've got
exclusive details she's trying to say
from a congressional investigation
that's raising some very serious
questions about whether groups meant to
make those donations happen are really
doing enough our consumer investigative
reporter Anna Werner also spoke to a
woman whose life is in the balance
it's a daily battle
this is what dominates laquia gold
Ring's life
four hours a day five days a week
sitting hooked up to a machine for home
dialysis it's the only way to clean her
blood while she waits for a kidney
transplant to keep her alive I only have
one shot at a transplant and until I get
that call my life is dependent upon a
machine a lot of dialysis patients are
sitting around like me just wondering
when will we get the call she's been
waiting for seven years and I feel like
the longer that I wait the closer I am
to death patients like gold ring rely on
non-profit groups that secure organs for
transplants from deceased donors they're
called organ procurement organizations
or opos but a house subcommittee
investigating the organ donation and
Transplant system in the U.S says opos
are failing to secure many organs that
could be recovered subcommittee chair
representative Raja krishnamurthy 17 to
20 people a day die on the wait list
because they can't get organs and the
opos are just not recovering enough
organs and making sure they're getting
into people who need them in August the
Senate finance committee said it's two
and a half year investigation found from
the top down the U.S transplant network
is not working putting Americans lives
at risk and now in a letter sent to opos
yesterday the house subcommittee is
Raising questions about whether data
provided by opos may be inaccurate and
incomplete if you don't have proper data
then you don't know what organs exist
and are usable to to go into people who
need them several opos told us in
response their data is accurate and
they're committed to saving lives the
United Network for organ sharing eunos
said its systems are audited annually
and eunos's Dr Matt Cooper the board
president at the time told us in May the
data clearly demonstrates that year over
year our transplant system continues to
be more and more successful but not
everyone in the system agrees Matt
Wadsworth heads one of those opos in
Ohio do you believe that many of the
opos Nationwide are failing absolutely
he's the chief executive of opo Life
Connection in Dayton in his first two
years there he says his organization
doubled the number of organ donors in
his region which meant many more lives
saved at the house subcommittee's
Hearing in 2021 Wadsworth told members
of Congress other opos should be doing
better too opioids are grossly
inefficient and unaccountable
unaccountable he says because before
this year when the government changed
the way opios are evaluated some opos
were able to make their numbers look
better than they actually were so you're
the head of an opio and you're saying
yeah a lot of these guys were
manipulating their data yeah
and when they manipulated the data what
did it make it look like
that they were going after every
opportunity every time they were
converting every possible patient to be
a successful organ donor and that's just
it's not the truth and they're the same
bad players if you look at the data it's
the same people low performing year
after year the association of Oregon
procurement organization says its
members are doing a good job that in the
last five years opos have increased the
number of deceased organ donors by 35
percent but it agreed that improvements
are necessary to advance care for
patients like liquia gold ring it's
heartbreaking it it truly brings tears
to my eyes because I'm like that's more
patients that are going to die or more
patients that are going to be stuck
waiting on that list
something that even this opo director
became so emotional about during our
interview I was Tower
he had to leave for a moment to compose
himself why does that make you so
emotional
I because there's people dying
you know
yes wow
wow goodness new regulations passed
during the Trump Administration set new
standards for opos and a process to
decertify them if they're below a par
but that won't happen until 2026 the
emotion that he showed at the end number
one you can't fake that it shows that he
deeply cares and also says seems to be a
big problem there we're talking about
people's lives exactly life or death yes
it really is all right Joanna Warner
once again Anna Warner on the case